I'm like scatter right now I bet you see
welcome back how was your vacation it
was amazing thank you guys so much for
the itinerary no tell me you went to
that cafe best biscotti I've ever had
that is Scottie you ruined me for
American biscotti did you go in the hi
yes oh the Vista well the vistas in
America are trash did you yes amazing
what is this place Oh Kate the beauty is
indescribable but here's what it look
like it's God's country I'm gonna have
an eighth of my ashes scattered there
and we've seen truths before they call
it a vile jovial uh it's economically
decimated but culturally its bursting
with riches I bought a magnet with my
name on it
there's this restaurant it's in the
ocean you have to try it now you're
gonna get wet but that's part of it you
must try the Eucharist at the Cathedral
ruined me for American to arrest the
best ruins I've ever seen ruined me for
American ruins now I don't oversell it
but let's just say you are finally gonna
understand what I started spelling color
could be you
[Applause]
[Music]
so how was it it was amazing you to have
to go okay